depuis 1994
hélène travail à les aides de trappes
elle est passée par la blanchisserie
mais effectue à présent des tâches de
sous traitance aujourd'hui elle reçoit
la médaille du travail avec une certaine
appréhension 7 ce qui était beaucoup de
conditionnement et du conditionnement je
fais tout ce qui a franchi cement
récompense les années d'ancienneté de
haut niveau travail quatre activités
sont proposées à ses travailleurs en
situation de handicap la restauration la
blanchisserie les espaces verts et la
sous-traitance
l'objectif de la structure et de
responsabiliser ses salariés pour les
rendre autonomes ils sont 145
le but pour nous la mission de lézardes
c'est d'essayer de rapporter le plus
d'autonomie tout en les protégeant
donc en fait l'autonomie ça passe par
quoi ça passe par une rémunération par
un travail et le travail c'est ce qu'on
essaye de leur donner ici et ce qui se
passe très bien pour l'instant
lionel vient de recevoir sa médaille du
travail cela fait 22 ans qu'il travaille
dans l'espace vert de cet établissement
pour lui cette médaille représente la
reconnaissance de ses efforts pour moi
je suis content de décrire
oui si on dit en pains au travail je
suis pas content pour eux
on a ça s'est bien passé des portes
ouvertes qui permettent à les hâte de
fêter leurs 40 ans et de mettre en avant
leur engagement au service des personnes
en situation de handicap